معنا من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد
العمري وليد اذا صباح صعب كما يصفه
مسؤولون اسرائيليون ماذا في اخر ردود
الفعل حول ما حدث ولكن قبل ان تجيبني انوه
الى هذا الخبر العاجل عن مستشفى سروك
الاسرائيلي استقبلنا امس يقول المستشفى
سبعه عسكريين جرحى بينهم حالتان خطيرتان
اصيبوا في معارك بجنوب غزه اليك
وليد نعم الاسرا ليون وعلى كافه المستويات
الاعلاميه والرسميه وكذلك العسكريه يصفون
هذه الليله وصباح هذا اليوم بانه كارثه
وبانه قاس وصعب وان ما جرى يشير الى ان
امس كان اقسى واصعب ايام القتال في قطاع
غزه اوقع هذا العدد الكبير من القتلى
والجرحى في صفوف القوات الاسرائيليه لا
سما نصف المبنيين الذين تواجد داخلهما
قوات من الهندسه ومن الاحتياط ضباط وجنود
والتي كانت على تبعد نحو 600 متر فقط من
الشريط الحدودي بين قطاع غزه ومنطقه وسط
غلاف غزه منطقه كيسوفيم
الاسرائيليون سواء الرئيس الاسرائيلي
اسحاك هيرتسوغ وزير الماليه سموتريتش
وايضا وزير الدفاع جلنت جميعهم وصفوا ذلك
بانه كان ضربه قاسيه ومؤلمه وموجعه جدا
لكن جميعهم اكدوا على ان الحرب هذه كما
قال وزير الدفاع جلنت هذه وصيتهم اي وصيه
الذين قتلوا للمضي في الحرب حتى تحقيق
اهدافها الرئيس الاسرائيلي هو الاخر وصف
ذلك بانه يوم قاس جدا ومؤلم للغايه وكذلك
كان سمتش ووزراء اخرين الصحافه
الاسرائيليه تقول بانه من اصعب او انه
اصعب ايام القتال منذ ان بدا الجيش
الاسرائيلي اجتياحه البري لقطاع غزه
اللافت فيما جرى بالاضافه الى العدد
الكبير للقتلى والحديث هنا عن 21 ضابطا
وجنديا الذين قتلوا في قصف ونصف مبنيين
كانا يعملان على تفخيخ هما تمهيدا لتفجيره
ما في منطقه المغازي مخيم المغازي في
المحافظه الوسطى من قطاع غزه وفي مسافه
تبع نحو 600 متر فقط من منطقه غلاف غزه
قباله بلده كيسوفيم هذا مؤشر على ان حتى
هذه المناطق التي يقول الجيش الاسرائيلي
منذ فتره بانه قد تمكن من اجتياحها وانه
قضى على المقاومه الفلسطينيه فيها ليست
فقط ليست امنه وانما يتلقى فيها اقصى
الضربات هذا يضاف اليه ايضا المعارك
الطاحنه التي تدور في منطقه مخيم خانيونس
وغرب خان يونس بعد ان دفع بسبع كتائب الى
من قواته المشتركه الكوماندوز والهندسه
واليابسه الى هذه المنطقه من اجل تطويق
مخيم خان يونس باعتباره قلب المعقل
الاساسي لقياده قوات القسام ويشتبه بان
بالانفاق في تلك المنطقه وكان قد كشف عددا
منها ربما يحتجزون عددا كبيرا من الرها
والاسرى الاسرائيليين وكان ايضا قد اعلن
انه قد طوق مدينه خانيونس ايضا من الناحيه
الجنوبيه اي الجنوبيه التي توصل الى منطقه
شرق رفح وايضا الى الحدود مع مصر وانه
اجتاح كافه المناطق القريبه منها مثل
خزاعه والقرار وبني سهيله وعبس وهي الاكثر
قربا من الحدود مع اسرائيل لكن الضربه
جاءته هذه المره تماما من داخل المنطقه
الوسطى وتحديدا في محيط مخيم المغازي
الاقرب الى الحدود والمبني هما على مقربه
من هذه الحدود نحو 600 متر كل منهما من
طابقين حسب بيان الناطق العسكري
الاسرائيلي قبل قليل فان هذه القوات كانت
قد اتمت عمليه تفخيخ المبنيين لنصفه
باعتبارهما حسب قوله جزءا من البنى
التحتيه الارهابيه في المنطقه
ولتاكيد المناطق الجنوبيه لكن اطلقت قذائف
الار بي جي على دبابه وايضا على المبنيين
وهو ما ادى الى تفجيره بالكامل وانهياره
على من فيهما من جنود وضباط وظلت عمليه
محاوله تخليص الجثث
والجرحى مستمره منذ نحو الرابعه من عصر
يوم امس حتى فجر هذا اليوم ليتبين ان هناك
على الاقل 21 قتيلا وكان اخرون ثلاثه قتلى
من الضباط وثلاث ثلاثه جنود ايضا قد
اصيبوا بجراح خطيره للغايه في المعارك
الدائره في منطقه خانيونس وتحديدا منطقه
مخيم خانيونس وغرب خانيونس هذا الوضع يصفه
الاسرائيليون بانه ربما وضع الحرب
على مفترق طرق لكن هناك اصرار على
الاستمرار بهذه الحرب حتى تحقيق اهدافها
من وجهه نظرهم وفق ما جاء في كافه
التصريحات الحاصله ايه الضربه التي تلقاها
الجيش الاسرائيلي تذكر ايضا
بضربه كان قد تلقاها في حي الشجاعيه
الشرقي لمدينه غزه وكان قد قتل هناك نحو
تسعه جنود ايضا في ضربه مماثله داخل احدى
المباني بعد ان نسفوا نسفت المقاومه وقصفت
مبنى تواجدوا داخله وفجرت الغام لكن هذه
الضربه هي الاقوى التي يتلقاها الجيش
الاسرائيلي منذ ما بعد طوفان الاقصى ومنذ
السابع من اكتوبر وخلال اجتياحه البري
لقطاع غزه والان يقف في قراره نحو ما اذا
سيواصل نحو منطقه رفح الجنوبيه المتاخمه
للحدود مع مصر ومحور فيلا دلفي وهي الشريط
الحدودي الفاصل بطول 14 كيل مت ونصف من
البحر حتى منطقه كرم ابو سالم بين جنوبي
قطاع غزه
ومصر وهذه الامور على ما يبدو تتعلق
بقرارات سياسيه قبل ان تتعلق بقرارات
عسكريه لانه قد تكون لها تداعيات كبيره
جدا خاصه ب ما يتعلق باعاده احتلال محور
فيلادلفيا والاخطر هو ان يتواصل الاجتياح
الى المناطق الغربيه الشماليه لمدينه رفح
على وجه الخصوص ومنطقه المواصي حي المقتضى
بالنازحين الفلسطينيين وهناك مئات الالاف
منهم الذين نزحوا سواء من شمالي القطاع
منذ بدايه الحرب او نزحوا من منطقه خان
يونس الى هذه المناطق لذلك هذا اليوم ال
2ب الساعه الماضيه تحديدا يوم امس يعتبر
قاسيا وموجع ومؤلما جدا للاسرائيليين وقد
منيوا فيه باكبر خساره بالارواح في صفوف
قواتهم بضربات وكمائن نصبتها المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في تلك المنطقه والاهم من هذا
كله انها جاءت في مناطق كان يعتقد بانه قد
اتم احتلالها او كما كان يتحدث تطهيرها
وخاصه في الوسطى في قطاع غزه ومنطقه مخيم
المغازي عندما نتحدث عن الوسطى هي المنطقه
التي فيها مدينه دير البلح ومخيمات
المغازي والبريج والنصيرات وكان قد قصفها
جوا بشكل هائل خلال الفتره الماضيه لكن
المغازي هو ال الضربه جاءته من منطقه مخيم
المغازي وهي ضربه يصفها الاسرائيليون
بانها كارثه
لهذا العدد الكبير من الخسائر بالارواح
التي مني بها